the hustle and energy from Vanderbilt as
Darren Jackson knocks him down Davis
Falling Away got no good the follow is
good canarn a three
Russell the running start
beautiful pass hachimura filling the
lane
James the crossover gets inside powers
in can't get a default fight for the
rebound Jackson lost it hachimura right
there and puts it back up and in
official scores
Russell Cross Court hachimura Corner
three got it
[Applause]
karate trying to muscle Russell
hachimura another open look another
three-pointer Roy hachimura
no Vanderbilt a huge part of that
turn around defensively
achimura they're letting him shoot
hachimura knocks down another 17 points
in 17 minutes for hachimura
instead of staying four on the perimeter
Machi Moore is going to try again puts
it in Brewing hachimura
hachimura down the lane rui hachimura
what a game achimura
that his best game as a Laker and he
saved it for game one of the opening
round of the playoffs turn shoots and
scores Roy hachimura 24 points and I'm
still okay if hachimura is the shooter
Reeves fakes Reeves behind the back
hachimura three-pointer puts it in
Brewing hachimura
and then he said he's okay with
hachimura taking a shot I call this a
rui Awakening
Crooks trying to get off the three Davis
contestant Brooks way off
achimura picks it up hachimura looks of
the rim goes up and throws it down and
that'll do it